dans le débat sur France 24 les forces
russes se retirent de la région de
Kerson le ministère russe de la Défense
l'a annoncé hier les Ukrainiens en doute
les forces d'occupation russes avaient
évacuées 115 000 personnes de la région
se retraits bien sûr un revers pour les
Russes une preuve que Moscou a de vrais
problèmes à lancer Joe Biden lors d'une
conférence de presse hier soir ce
retrait serait une nouvelle victoire
pour Kief à lancer yens stoetenberg le
secrétaire général de l'OTAN l'armée
ukrainienne a annoncé quant à elle avoir
repris aujourd'hui 12 localités dans la
région alors où en est la situation à
Kerson les Russes se sont-ils
véritablement retirés et si c'est le cas
comment analyser ce retrait quel est
leur stratégie pourquoi les Ukrainiens
sont-ils sceptiques dans quelle mesure
un tel retrait est-il un revers pour
Moscou la chute de Kerson serait-elle
véritablement un tournant dans cette
guerre et bien on va poser toutes ces
questions à mes invités j'ai le plaisir
d'avoir à mes côtés qui rigoles ton
bonsoir
spécialistes des régimes communistes et
postes soviétiques auteur d'une histoire
mondiale du communisme donc c'est chez
Grasset bienvenue à vous en face de vous
Denis strelcoff bonsoir journaliste à
RFI bienvenue dans le débat Denis à côté
de vous Oksana microfanova bonsoir
Roxana enseignante chercheuse à l'INALCO
cherche le Seigneur également à
l'Institut d'histoire mondiale de
l'Académie nationale des sciences
d'Ukraine à Kiev bienvenue à vous nous
avons avec nous Gulliver crag notre
correspondant à Kiev bonsoir Gulliver
et merci d'être avec nous dans le débat
c'est le ministre de la Défense rue
sergueil shoego qui a ordonné donc le
retrait des forces russes de Kerson lors
d'une réunion avec le commandant des
opérations russes en Ukraine vous allez
voir que les Ukrainiens doutent toujours
de ce retrait on fait d'abord un point
en images avec Étienne paponon
rien ne nous a surpris mais nous savons
que nous devrons encore nous battre
les troupes russes sont ordres de
franchir le Nièvre pour se regrouper sur
la rive est hors de cette ville
stratégique proche de la Crimée toujours
discret lorsqu'il s'agit de donner des
détails concrets des batailles le
président ukrainien ne révèle rien de
l'opération militaire en cours
il y a eu beaucoup de joie aujourd'hui
et nous comprenons clairement pourquoi
mais nos émotions doivent toujours être
contenues en période de guerre
je ne donnerai pas l'ennemi tous les
détails de nos opérations que ce soit
dans le sud à l'est à l'ouest nulle part
quand nous obtiendrons des résultats
tout le monde le verra
une méfiance partagée dans les rues de
Kiev
ironnement
russes jouent à quelque chose on ne
devrait pas leur faire confiance
ce n'est pas pour rien qu'ils ont
rassemblé 40000 soldats là-bas je pense
qu'il prépare quelque chose contre
l'armée ukrainienne les autorités
redoutent une difficile bataille urbaine
qui piègerait leur troupes les
Ukrainiens connaissent le prix du sang
selon l'armée américaine cent mille
dollars soldats ont été tués ou blessés
depuis neuf mois selon ces mêmes
estimations les troupes russes auraient
subis les mêmes pertes
alors on attend le vice-amiral Michel au
lagara et qui va nous rejoindre en cours
d'émission pour justement parler de la
stratégie militaire Gulliver pourquoi et
est-ce que c'est toujours le cas
pourquoi les Ukrainiens doutent-ils de
ce retrait des Russes alors en partie je
pense que c'est leur manière habituelle
si vous vous rappelez quand la Russie
avait annoncé le départ de la région de
Kiev la réponse de l'Ukraine au départ
était aussi très prudent en disant on va
voir ce qu'ils vont réellement faire on
ne croit pas les Russes sur parole ça
c'est presque une question de principe
en Ukraine mais ils l'ont aussi des
renseignements qui leur indiquent qu'il
y a un certain nombre de soldats russes
qui sont maintenant habillés en civils
qui ont investi des maisons à Herson un
certain nombre de préparatifs pour une
défense de la ville même si ils disent
aussi les Ukrainiens observaient des
mouvements militaires russes qui
pourraient être des signes d'un retrait
mais générale leur principe c'est
toujours de attendre de voir ce qui va
se passer
l'annonce qui a été fait à la télévision
une manière un peu théâtrale aussi c'est
un peu
soulève des soupçons je pense à cause de
cela et aussi le fait que les rues
soient certainement pu défendre la rive
droite dans la région de personnes un
peu plus longtemps que ce qu'ils ont
fait cela vient tout un petit peu plus
tôt que prévu cela aussi fait que les
Ukrainiens sont très prudents dans leur
interprétation des indications des
Russes vous êtes d'accord donc les
Ukrainiens doutent toujours vous qui
êtes ukrainienne vous doutez de ce
retrait ou est-ce qu'effectivement il y
a un certain nombre de signes en
l'occurrence les Ukrainiens ont dit
aujourd'hui qu'ils avaient pris 12
localités il y a un certain nombre de
signes qui montreraient qui pousseraient
tout de même à dire que le retrait bien
lieu
bien sûr le plus important en Ukraine
c'est écouter la position de
l'état-major ukrainien voilà donc dès
que le temps majeur ukrainien n'a pas
annoncé que quels sont les prix par
l'armée ukrainienne il faut rester
prudent quels sont les signes que par
exemple l'armée ukrainienne peut prendre
une ville d'abord c'est le drapeau qui
se trouve sur place mais aussi il faut
pas oublier que fort probable les
rousses sont bien menés la ville et tout
qui est à côté imaginons que on a mis
les mines on ne peut partout donc le
processus de plantes la vie la ville
sera très compliqué donc du coup moi
j'ai quand même conseillé de suivre la
position de ministère de défense
ukrainienne de l'État majeur ukrainien
que la confirmation doit venir de la
part de l'état-major de crème denistre
parce que c'est vrai que le secrétaire
général de l'OTAN on va l'écouter un peu
plus tard dit que ça serait une victoire
pour Kiev les Américains ont l'air de
dire que ce retrait tout de même a lieu
bah si on dit différentes sources
auxquelles on a accès effectivement oui
les Russes sont en train de quitter
personne est déjà c'est une processus
qui a commencé il y a bien longtemps il
y a quelques semaines et même quand
monsieur sorikin a annoncé qu'il y aura
des divisions difficiles à prendre
c'était quand même l'idée que quelqu'un
sera abandonné parce que c'était bien
expliqué à la télé russe pour une fois
c'est vrai que il a plus de plus de sens
de garder l'armée dans cette ville là
car cela vient de plus en plus cher en
termes des hommes en terme de munition
de le tenir donc effectivement par
contre il faut bien comprendre que on
est aussi dans une guerre de
communication donc c'est que chaque
message qui provient de l'armée russe y
compris des messages comme on a vu un
peu spectaculaire à la télé ça
effectivement un but et pas uniquement
un but pour communiquer avec l'armée
avec la population mais aussi de faire
différents signes aux Ukrainiens ça peut
être aussi un signe que la Russie peut
se préparer des éventuels négociations
peut-être pas de peine au monde de
cesser le feu donc il y a tout ça mais
dans tous les cas il faut bien sûr ce
qui se passe sur le terrain on voit
qu'il y a des ocriniens qui entre un peu
dans des villes aux alentours de kirson
et que aussi les Russes ont
effectivement que vous avez dit
minestria infrastructure et ils ont
aussi fait exploser la tour de
télévision donc effectivement le but
mettant des Russes c'est de abandonner
cette ville là mais peut-être de la
laisser sans communication
infrastructures pour ne pas laisser une
base stable pour tout le monde pour
s'installer Oxana alors justement vous
qui êtes l'historien de ce plateau en
quoi personne est ici symbolique moi
j'ai lu qu'effectivement Grégory Potter
Keane la mont favorite de Catherine II
un militaire qui a colonisé
le corps donc c'est un symbole Vladimir
Poutine a l'air dit tenir en tout cas
personne excusez-moi c'était une grande
ville d'abord la plus grande ville
qu'ils avaient prise et d'ailleurs ce
qu'ils ont pris Séville on a oublié ça
je vous signale parce que c'est c'est
parti dans le dans le flou de
l'information on a oublié que cette
ville a été prise grâce parce qu'on sait
grâce en partie une trahison intérieure
ukrainienne puisque le responsable de la
ville a été arrêté
deux ou trois quatre mois plus tard
accusé justement d'avoir favorisé
l'entrée des des Russes dans cette ville
parce que c'était pas si facile parce
qu'il y avait quand même il y a ce
fleuve le diable qui est gigantesque qui
fait presque 1 km à certains endroits
bon donc ils y tiennent parce que
c'était un symbole c'était la plus
grande ville qu'ils avaient prise n'est
ce pas donc ça c'est un symbole
militaire et puis que je crois
principalement et on verra bien quand le
Bisma l'amiral sera là je pense que
stratégiquement c'était plus tenable en
tout cas
compte tenu de des forces et contenu
n'oublions pas qu'à ce fleuve donc c'est
une ville qui est divisée en deux c'est
très important de le voir c'est divisé
en deux donc si vous voulez ceux qui
défendent la partie
occidentale du fleuve si vous voulez son
dos aux fleurs hein donc rapatrier c'est
et donc irisé de coincé si vous voulez
si vous avez une offensive au crédit m²
ils ont pas ils ont plus de capacité de
repris d'autant plus il y a plus de pour
maintenant ils ont beaucoup tous les
ponts ont été détruit donc c'est aussi
une raison de sauvegarder un peu des
armes ils en ont perdu tellement que à
mon avis c'est c'est une question de
prudence même si c'est une défaite je
pense être on peut interpréter ça comme
une défaite de l'armée à Russie la
séquence en tout cas de cette annonce
entre shoyu le fameux ministre de la
Défense russe et le général russe Soro
Viking est assez particulière on va la
regarder
camarade ministre de la défense après
une évaluation complète de la situation
actuelle nous suggérons de nous défendre
le long de la rive gauche du fleuve
comprenez que ce n'est pas une décision
simple à prendre mais en même temps nous
allons préserver la vie de nos
militaires préparer les forces armées au
combat
rester sur la rive droite du fleuve dans
une zone limitée et sans perspective
grâce à cela une partie de nos soldats
sera libérée et utilisé pour d'autres
activités comme celle de nature
offensive dans d'autres directions en
Ukraine
Sergueï Vladimir je suis d'accord avec
vos conclusions et vos suggestions pour
nous la vie des militaires russes est
toujours une priorité nous devons
également tenir compte du danger pour la
population civile veillez à ce que tous
les civils préférant partir puissent le
faire
un peu a déjà vu tirez-vous le temps
c'est un peu un déjà vu cette séquence
quand on entend le général le
responsable de l'armée dire que ils sont
la vie des hommes c'est très important
vu ce qu'ils en ont sacrifié c'est quand
même incroyable c'est voilà je trouve
qu'il y a une espèce d'ironie là parce
que c'est en vérité enfin c'est assez
clair comme situation à comprendre à mon
avis c'est que d'abord l'hiver arrive
c'est très important n'est-ce pas donc
le front va être gelé donc évidemment il
quitte la rive occidentale du diep ils
vont se mettre oriental et donc ils vont
essayer de réconcilier un peu une armée
ils sont dans une situation très
délicate et russe parce que les hommes
qui sont qui sont qui sont amenés sur le
front donc presque pas de formation ils
ont pas ils ont pas de matériel moi j'ai
des témoignages incroyables et je pense
que ça sera confirmé par rapport aux
camarades russes donc voilà donc ils ont
donc ils ont besoin de de se reposer si
je puis dire et de reprendre une ligne
de défense voilà et donc abandonner la
partie
occidentale de Carson c'est une c'est du
bon sens pour retenir militairement
parlant c'est pour mieux protéger la
Crimée je poserai bien sûr la question à
notre ami qui va nous rejoindre
denistral koff mais on parle
effectivement en général américain
aurait dit qu'il y avait 100000 morts et
blessés côté russe et que ça serait
probablement d'ailleurs la même chose
côté
ukrainien c'est en tout cas le chef
d'état-major de l'armée américaine Marc
Miller qui l'a dit à l'économie Club of
New York donc il y a véritablement des
pertes très importantes côté russe
d'après les Américains en début de la
guerre puis donc on n'est pas du tout
sur au niveau des chiffres car il y a
aussi des médias russe qui disent qu'il
serait peut-être aussi beaucoup plus
mais le vrai problème qui en fait c'est
même pas le nombre des personnes qui ont
travaillé au front car il y a eu une
grande partie qui sont maintenant des
militaires de Wagner donc de cette
fameuse mélisse et qui a été utilisée
depuis les débuts de la guerre
d'ailleurs par la Russie donc
effectivement on sera plutôt entre
disons 50 et 150 000 donc la fourchette
elle est quand même assez importante
mais tout ce qui est maintenant été dit
par Monsieur sorry King les mots qu'on
vient de transcrire je dois quand même
la mettre c'est donc c'est un peu pour
ça qu'ils ont pris sa décision là car
c'est une ville qui était une sorte de
recadrage de la défense pour moi ce qui
est important ce qui a fait c'était une
décision qui est annoncée par Poutine
pas par ce goût on part sur wiki en fait
lui il est pas responsable c'est session
lui non plus car lui elle était il a
commencé son
le commandement de l'armée russe il y a
quelques mois donc quand la station sur
le front a été déjà pas et c'est déjà un
marché pas bien pour l'armée donc il y a
un peu tout ça il y a quand même dans
cette guerre de communication c'est pas
Poutine qui annonce les divisions
difficiles mais c'est plutôt ce rikin
qui lui n'est pas aussi responsable donc
maintenant ce qui va se passer dans les
prochaines semaines sur le front au
niveau de communication sur le front de
communication au moins ceux qui sont
victimes va essayer d'envoyer l'armée
qui a été qui est maintenant libre dans
ses actions plutôt vers d'autres fronts
pour essayer quand même un peu de à mon
hiver avant que le front effectivement
soit gelé de avancer un tout petit peu
plus pour livrer une victoire au moins
symbolique si jamais ça aura lieu à la
population russe car ça c'est important
on n'a jamais admis à la télévision que
c'était effectivement la le défaite de
la Russie donc on va essayer de donner
d'autres choses à la population donc il
y a une vraie stratégie derrière
excusez-moi je reviens sur la sur le
passage combien de l'avoir la mise en
scène est extraordinaire c'est
typiquement ici bien sûr de type
soviétique excusez-moi
vous demander si ça vous rappeler des
souvenirs parce que c'est parce que je
veux dire quand on voit le général dire
monsieur le ministre je veux dire voilà
c'est incroyable c'est jouer bien sûr je
veux dire tout a été prévu d'avance
voilà et c'est marrant qu'ils effacé
marrant s'amuse sincèrement à quel point
ils sont quand même assez désespéré si
je puis dire parce que militairement ils
sont assez désespéré quand même je pense
je pense qu'il faut parler pas
uniquement quelques communication russe
mais peut-être l'avancement de l'armée
ukrainienne au Sud par exemple le temps
major ukrainienne rappelle qu'il faut
pas croire du tout en bonne volonté de
Russie en bonne volonté de se retirer
mais tout simplement c'est le résultat
le résultat de l'armée ukrainienne vers
le Sud par exemple on ne parle pas
peut-être trop mais l'armée ukrainienne
se détruit c'est en train de détruire
par exemple un point logistique de russe
aussi il y a le bombardement de stock
diminution russe donc tout ça c'est
traitement c'est aussi ces conditionnel
par l'avance de l'armée ukrainienne tout
simplement Gulliver peut-être que vous
pouvez me dire un mot à la fois sur les
conditions de vie de Carson vous étiez à
carquish il n'y a pas très longtemps et
puis justement sur est-ce que sur place
on a le sentiment quand même que les
Ukrainiens s'approche se rapproche de la
ville de Kerson
alors d'abord il se rapproche rapidement
puisque les 12 localités que vous avez
mentionnées c'est ce que ils ont pris
officiellement selon les allogénies chef
de l'état-major c'est dernier 24 heures
c'est sans doute plus déjà parce qu'il y
a des photos de nouvelles localité avec
le drapeau
ukrainien et ça c'est 12 ans 24 heures
sur 41 depuis le premier octobre donc il
y a une accélération très marquée de
l'avancée des troupes ukrainiennes vers
Herson mais ils sont pas encore arrivés
à la ville même pour ce qui est des
conditions de vie dont personne ne sait
pas grand chose
d'essayer de attiser ce genre de conflit
franchement personnellement je pense pas
que ça va marcher très bien mais je
pense qu'il est possible qu'ils aient
quelque chose comme ça en tête il
fallait utiliser une sorte de chaos tu
ris volton
je suis pas convaincu qu'il y a beaucoup
de gens qui restent à Carson je pense
qu'il y a effectivement ils ont quand
même beaucoup évacué de personnes
c'est ce qu'ils disent en tout cas
première chose et deuxièmement la
prudence des Ukrainiens se comprend tout
à fait et je vais vous raconter un petit
précédent historique
qui à mon avis est très marquant même si
évidemment le contexte n'a rien à voir
mais enfin bon voilà elle a mi-octobre
l'armée allemande était enfin avant
c'est très très vite sur sur Moscou
d'accord donc il a été question d'évacu
Moscou et donc ça a été la décision
était prise immédiatement donc les gens
sont partis etc et ordre a été donné
ordre a été donné de miner l'ensemble de
la ville sauf le métro et et et et
conduite d'eau donc on met une tout le
pays tout toute la ville donc vous
rendez compte que évidemment vraiment
c'est pas possible puisque finalement
lors de a été stoppé et ils ont décidé
de défendre Moscou et il y a pas eu
d'évacuation de secours mais il est il
est évident à mon avis que le temps
qu'il s'est passé entre le moment où ils
ont décidé d'évacuer tout ça ils ont
forcément mis des mines etc et que
évidemment les Ukrainiens ils ont pas
intérêt à rentrer comme ça parce que ça
peut être un massacre pour eux quoi
Oxana c'est son aussi les informations
vous avez de la côté ukrainien à la fois
donc privé effectivement un peu de tout
sur place une tentative aussi de créer
une sorte de chaos cette évacuation des
par les prorus juste avant de 100000
habitants de Carson
c'est bien de connu déjà c'est la
tactique russe se détruire par exemple
les entreprises qui produisent de
l'énergie partout dans dans le pays en
you prince déjà tactique et employé
depuis plusieurs semaines donc c'est
très logique ensuite l'explosion de tour
de la télé mais on ne peut pas par
exemple mener canalisation
l'infrastructure qui est très différente
pour la ville et les entreprises qui
produisent le chauffage donc du du coup
tout simplement
laisser après eux des ruines de ruines
ou c'est pas possible de vivre surtout
après les verres donc c'est se faire la
vie c'est insupportable mais je pense
que quand même aussi il faut attirer
attention maintenant on parle de garçon
c'est très important mais il faut
prendre en compte par exemple que notre
porte parole de force aérienne il a
annoncé qui il faut rester très prudente
parce que exactement maintenant
peut-être la Russie fait stock de
missiles elle essaie de cumuler beaucoup
de missiles et beaucoup de trompes pour
faire le bombardement le bombardement
mais le bombé personne ou les
bombardements a peut-être d'autres
villes c'est pas nécessairement des
questions mais de débordement de
bombardements de Kiev il sait que en
partant de prendre en compte quand il y
a le bombardement par exemple quelques
missiles ou quelques dons pour les
forces
ukrainiennes de défense interne c'est
plus simple si il s'agit de la situation
quand la Russie va lancer vraiment
beaucoup de missiles et beaucoup de
drone parce que il y a le pourcentage de
drones à domicile qui arrive et
détruisent les entreprises de nager ce
sera plus augmenter donc du coup il faut
prendre aussi ça en compte que
après le succès admettons militaire
ukrainien il y a l'avant de gens de la
part de route et voilà vengeance c'est
qui mais bien sûr civile parce que c'est
très simple le réaliser donc les
vengeance en fait qui aurait démarré par
cette sorte de simulacre
la tactique préférée bombarder tout
simplement les infrastructures en
énergétiques
affrontement regarder comme ça ça compte
à l'ennemi c'est à l'ennemi et ukrainien
pour les Russes c'est plus facile
évidemment moi je l'aurais pas appelé
c'est une vengeance je pense que c'est
un peu aussi le but de la communication
de crumble de dire que en fait on se
venge parce que vous avez détruit vous
avez fait frapper le pont de la Crimée
vous avez avancer sur le terrain non
c'est une stratégie de la Russie c'est
assez nouveau quand même donc c'est un
peu arrivé avec le survie Kim qui est
appris en charge l'armée donc c'est un
peu ça qu'il a fait également un Siri en
bombardant des structures de
l'électricité notamment et maintenant vu
que la Russie il faut bien le dire les
généraux russes années quand même assez
bien
le système de fourniture d'électricité
ukrainienne parce que c'est aussi la
structure et qui est un peu construite à
la solitude donc pour la Russie de les
détruire si jamais il faut le faire ici
ils savent bien que le problème le plus
important avec l'arrivée de le faire ça
sera le chauffage car c'est pas du tout
le même système qu'en France chauffe pas
à l'électricité c'est beaucoup de
chauffage collectif qui est chauffé avec
du gaz avec avec d'autres types
d'énergie il faut aussi notamment donc
si jamais on détruisent ces systèmes là
les villes ils seront plus habitables
c'est aussi pour ça qu'il y a plusieurs
villes de Donbass qui sont sous contrôle
les Ukrainiens qui seront vite c'était
vers là parce que c'est impossible de
reconstruire le système d'ici quelques
mois donc c'est ça qui sera utilisé en
par la Russie peut-être à Kelson mais
aussi si jamais ils peuvent aussi
l'évocation potentielles d'équilibre et
le ici annoncé par des autorités
ukrainiennes si jamais là aussi il va
avancer ils ont déjà commencé d'ailleurs
parce que les bombardements qui ont eu
lieu sur Kiev et d'autres villes viser
des infrastructures de chauffage de
choses comme ça d'électricité etc donc
le drame pour les Ukrainiens du froid
qui arrive il est déjà commencé donc
c'est évidemment à craindre aussi ça en
tout cas pour Joe Biden se retrait russe
et la preuve que Moscou elle devrait
problème on va écouter le président
américain c'était hier lors de sa
conférence de presse
premièrement j'ai trouvé l'annonce du
retrait des troupes russes intéressantes
les rues sont attendus la fin des
élections américaines pour l'annoncer
alors que nous savions déjà depuis un
certain temps qu'ils allaient le faire
c'est la preuve que l'armée russe a de
vraies difficultés
deuxièmement que cette décision conduise
ou non un affaiblissement des combats
cela laissera le temps à chaque camp de
réévaluer ses positions pendant la
période hivernale reste à savoir si
ensuite l'Ukraine sera prête ou non à
faire un compromis avec la Russie
peut-être entre l'Ukrainien et russe
Oxana microfanova pour vous c'est dans
les pas question aujourd'hui
c'est très difficile de parler de
compromis qu'est-ce que on appelle des
compromis parce que la position
officielle de l'État
ukrainien quand même la femme de guerre
c'est le béret tous les territoires qui
étaient coupés par les Russes il s'agit
avec le climat qui est un accès mais
c'est qui est très important aussi se
punir les crimes de guerre il se pose la
question aussi de réparation de
réparation parce que le crâne est
vraiment se faire à cause de cette
guerre si on va pas punir les crimes de
guerre et si il n'a pas de réparation
c'est
c'est la situation c'est injuste donc on
va poser la question de Michael
compromis et avec qui et en même temps
on entend dire qu'il y a eu des
entretiens à très haut niveau justement
entre les équipes de conseillers de
Vladimir Poutine et celle
d'administration Biden en tout cas
c'était une révélation du du Wall Street
Journal qui disait que Jackson
Ivan le conseiller à la sécurité
nationale des États-Unis auraient eu des
entretiens avec le conseiller du Kremlin
Youri ou tchakov donc en fait on
commence à se reparler ou en tout cas on
se parle toujours
on se parlait toujours depuis le début
de la guerre on n'a jamais arrêté même
si l'économo-officiel peut être en en
parlait plus et toujours la
communication entre la Russie et les
États-Unis au moins pour éviter tout
accident nucléaire donc ça c'est une
chose par contre on voit bien que pour
les États-Unis pour le monde entier la
guerre commence à coûter cher notamment
en raison aussi de l'inflation qui est
de cette guerre d'énergie puis donc
aussi parce que le soutien économique a
l'Ukraine est aussi importantes pour
tous les pays pour la France notamment
et c'est pour ça que on peut donner
logique des états des États-Unis mais
aussi dans la logique des gouvernements
de l'Europe ce sera que la guerre soit
finie au plus vite possible mais par
contre pour les Ukrainiens ce sera très
difficile d'accepter l'autre chose que
les victoires et tout à fait y compris
d'un panier de manière politique car
l'immerzilinski ne peut pas dire qu'on
va arrêter la guerre avant de reprendre
notamment
des régions de données est-ce que de
legrances qui étaient faut que ceux
contre le l'Ukraine avant le 24 février
donc tout ça veut dire deux choses
d'abord que bien évidemment l'Occident
va commencer à parler avec elle a réussi
pour un peu poussé à des éventuels
négociations c'est sûr qu'il a reçu pas
qu'il était l'Ukraine tout de suite
comme ça mais par contre pour le crin
c'est difficile d'excepter notre choix
que de commencer de continuer à
combattre ce politiquement c'est pas
possible en tout cas ce que dit le
Washington administration Biden serait
en train d'encourager en coulisse et
dirigeant Ukrainiens à renouer avec un
processus de négociation avec Moscou
Thierry Breton
excusez-moi tout le monde la guerre
c'est quand même le pire des systèmes
soyons clair donc tout le monde a
intérêt à ce que les combats s'arrêtent
le problème dans cette affaire là c'est
les Ukrainiens je veux dire il faut il
faut pas non plus qu'il soit les dindons
de la farce si je puis dire parce
qu'évidemment il est il est clair que
les Européens veulent que ça s'arrête
ils disent pas ouvertement j'entends
bien mais on verra bien la sortie
d'hiver lorsqu'on aura bien froid et
qu'il faudra et cetera qu'il y aura
l'inflation qui va grimper etc bon bref
donc il est clair que du côté européen
il y a une volonté d'éventuellement
d'arriver une négociation du côté
américain parce que ça coûte aussi très
cher aux Américains n'oublions pas ils
ont ils ont oui et puis ils ont livré
considérablement du matériel et
d'ailleurs ils sont ils sont à nu si je
puis dire parce que ils ont livré tout
le baptême surplus maintenant ils sont
sur leur stock donc ils ont besoin si
jamais il y avait un conflit donc bref
donc actuellement il est évident que
tout le monde a intérêt enfin tout le
monde tout le monde extérieur à ce
conflit a intérêt pas les Ukrainiens
absolument pas les Ukrainiens parce que
il serait il serait déjà dans la fin de
cette affaire-là et de toute façon c'est
vrai que heureusement quand même que il
y a une phrase qui est répétée
régulièrement par byden par par Macron
aussi y compris récemment il a dit ça
dépend des Ukrainiens heureusement qu'on
dit ça parce que excusez-moi les
négociations ça dépend des Ukrainiens il
se mettront à la fabrication le jour ils
estiment qu'ils seront en capacité de
gagner ces négociations Oxana votre
ananas vous allez regarder les élections
d'ailleurs mi-mandat avec cette victoire
des républicains même si elle est pas
aussi forte que prévu à la Chambre des
Représentants et puis un débats
effectivement aux États-Unis important
sur l'aide à l'Ukraine on a vu voler des
meilleurs hélas qui a demandé aux
Américains de rester unis est-ce que
vous vous craignez effectivement
qu'aujourd'hui il soit peut-être trop
tôt pour demander aux Ukrainiens et
justement de s'asseoir à la table des
Russes toujours des discussions
d'abord elfe souligner bien sûr que pour
les Ukrainiens ces élections parce que
on dépend beaucoup de lait d'américaine
c'est exactement à l'aide des États-Unis
qui est conséquente pour le crâne et
aussi il faut se rappeler que quand même
de loi de
l'anglise dont le crâne vraiment
beaucoup de sport qui est les États-Unis
peuvent continuer cette ce qui n'était
pas garantie avec les résultats des
élections ensuite c'est qu'il s'agit de
négociation donc au poids de vue
strictement de loin donc notre Conseil
de sécurité voilà et là vous voyez que
on ne va pas faire de négociations avec
Poutine avec le pouvoir qui est sur
place mais c'est que ce qui est plus
important je trouve un négociation sur
quoi parce que la Russie quand elle part
de négociation elle insiste on va faire
négociation sur l'état du lieu qui est
actuelle qu'est-ce que ça signifie que
tout simplement le reçu veut garder le
territoire ouais donc le garder le
territoire occupé donc de garder garder
le crémeux et garder le don de base et
comment c'est possible de faire
négociation dans ce conditionnement
ouvertement je vois pas je pense que le
pluriel dans cette situation on peut
continuer éventuellement négociation
nous plutôt appliquer des médiateurs
pour continuer de résoudre le problème
de céréales donc l'exportation de
céréales oui peut-être négociation pour
assurer le sécurité de centrales
nucléaire éventuellement mais c'est
qu'il s'agit de te retrouver
ce qui reste plus rien dans l'avenir
proche Michel legarade bonsoir merci
d'avoir finalement réussi à nous
rejoindre sur ce plateau on sait que
vous aviez un problème de taxi
vis-à-miral ancien commandant de l'école
navale merci d'être avec nous à faire
refaire justement un petit point avec
vous d'un point de vue militaire on va
revenir sur cette carte de Carson on a
compris tout de même que cette chute de
Kerson Michel rocara et ça serait un
tournant dans cette guerre est-ce que
vous pouvez nous expliquer compliqué
justement un peu où on est ce front même
si on sait que les Ukrainiennes donnent
pas toutes les informations est-ce
qu'effectivement pour vous ce retrait
russe et important à ce qui montre
est-ce que c'est un revers pour la
Russie et comment ça se passe est-ce
qu'effectivement ils vont vers le sud du
Nièvre comment ça se passe sur le
terrain c'est un repli qui est
manifestement totalement justifié pour
nous expert militaire entre guillemets
il était évident que les Russes étaient
bloqués dans cette poche de Carson il
fallait donc en sortir et le génération
wiki d'ailleurs lorsqu'il a pris son son
commandement a dit il y aura des
décisions difficiles à prendre et c'est
lui qui les a annoncé c'est lui qu'on
avait mis un peu en avant il nous paraît
évident qu'il a pris ce commandement en
ayant discuté de la situation tactique
avec le plus haut niveau des Renault
parce que il pouvait pas rester comme ça
ce que veulent faire les Russes pour
l'instant en attendant l'arrivée
d'éventuelles renforts efficace c'est
mettre une barrière un front enterré
depuis le Nord jusqu'au Sud et surtout
laisser tomber cette poche de Carson qui
était une épine dans le pied mais qui
politiquement avait une importance
capitale pour Poutine parce que c'est un
camouflé supplémentaire c'est un revers
extraordinaire qui fait que d'ailleurs
c'est un peu pour cette raison que il
n'ira pas au G20 ah oui vous pensez on
va revenir là-dessus alors juste pour
terminer donc en fait les forces russes
sont en train de se mettre sur la
défensive quand on regarde la carte on
va la revoir j'espère parce que c'est
intéressant de visualiser justement
cette cette retrait russe et cette
avancée donc on voit en bleu l'avancée
un des tropiques crâniennes et puis donc
ce retrait on voit les flèches du
retrait russe vers le sud donc du Nièvre
est-ce que c'est pour mieux peut-être
protéger la Crimée est-ce que c'est ça
qu'ils ont en tête d'un point de vue
stratégique parce que si vous laissez
avancer extrêmement rapide que les
forces de rue se venus de Crimée avait
commencé à faire vers l'est et vers
l'ouest vers au dessin et vers Mario
Paul s'est trouvé bloqué pas vers Mario
Paul malheureusement mais c'est trouvé
bloqué maintenant
donc maintenant ils sont en sur la
défensive et il faut surtout pas pour
eux faut surtout pas que la Crimée
puisse être véritablement un nouvel
objectif pour le président zidinsky qui
lui-même a dit dans les conditions de
négociation que il fallait reprendre
aussi non seulement le dans le bas mais
aussi la Crimée donc ils essaient de
faire ce qui est assez normal c'est à
dire ce fortifier sur la rive orientale
du niètre et voir la carte et c'est ce
qu'ils font depuis un certain temps
d'ailleurs parce que il ne faut pas
croire que c'est la mise en scène
grotesque dans laquelle le général
demandait à chouigou l'autorisation de
se retirer c'était déjà fait depuis
longtemps parce que on le donne pas
cette indication là à la télévision donc
ils avaient commencé déjà à se préparer
il y a déjà des lignes de fortifications
il y a déjà des lignes de repli et de
protection sur la rive orientale du
niapre bien sûr mais l'avancée des
Ukrainiens sera très difficile ça a
souvent été souligné parce que tout va
être piégé les Russes auront
certainement protégé leur repli parce
qu'ils ne peuvent pas se replier en
désordre comme ça ça a l'air
relativement ordonné a donc été
relativement bien planifiée maintenant
ça veut dire qu'est-ce qu'on fait dans
ces cas-là pour justement faire en sorte
que les Ukrainiens n'avancent pas
rapidement on va miner le terrain on va
créer du chaos c'est un peu son
il peut y avoir des tirs n'a été à
d'artillerie qui parce que l'artillerie
c'est bien positionné il devrait y avoir
200 pièces d'artillerie sur la rive
orientale du Nièvre qui donc peuvent
tirer au-delà de Carson et peuvent
empêcher ou ralentir l'avancée des
troupes ukrainiennes justement pour en
revenir sur le G20 vous dites c'est
l'une des raisons pour lesquelles
Vladimir Poutine sera absent du G20 se
retrait russe de Carson je m'avance
peut-être un peu mais quand on subit
camoufler sur camoufler on est moins
crédible vis-à-vis des pays que l'on
espère rallier à sa cause en particulier
des pays africains etc Il vous a pas
échappé que à l'occasion la dernière
semble générale des Nations unies il y a
quand même 35 pays qui n'ont pas qui se
sont abstenus 5 qui ont voté pour la
Russie 35 qui sont absolus donc cela la
Russie essaie de les travailler
pour lui c'est un c'est un c'est un
affront tout ça donc il préfère
s'abstenir
une seule chose que vas-y Poutine a
voulu éviter pendant ce G20 c'est une
humiliation et il a déjà en souvenir qui
est assez qui lui est assez frappant
c'est quand elle est venue à Sydney pour
en Australie pour en sommeil de jouvence
également quand il y a eu où j'essaie de
je me trompe peut-être mais quand en
fait il est plusieurs leaders qui ont
très peu de lui parler surtout qu'il
était pas invité sur le dîner donc elle
a dû quitter un peu à la dernière minute
le sommet un peu à l'arrache comme ça
donc ça c'est très important donc il a
pas voulu subir ça encore une fois car
il peut bien dire qu'il a pas réussi à
convaincre avec son discours la légitime
son logique de la guerre à l'Occident
mais par contre il y a les pays toujours
qui font confiance à ceux que c'est pas
la Russie qui a envahi l'Ukraine mais
que c'est un peu le temps qu'il a
provoqué en quelque sorte donc il y a
toujours des partenaires à se trouver
notamment avec la guerre de céréales
avec les guerres de l'énergie avec
l'inflation donc elle a toujours cette
opportunité de se trouver de nouveaux
partenaires il faut aussi penser à la
Chine notamment donc il n'était pas la
Chine a refus d'entrer à en guerre et la
refusé de fournir de matière réelle
militaire mais par contre il n'est pas
le prénom non plus donc c'est à dire que
au dépend de vie diplomatique la Russie
peut toujours essayer de gagner encore
plus de points sur le terrain c'est ça
le logique et russe et pour ça il vaut
mieux envoyer messieurs par exemple ou
d'autres personnages
dans ce cas là même si leur un échec ce
sera papi qui en sera responsable et ce
qui est beaucoup moins pénible pour le
kremlan Oxana un commentaire peut-être
justement sur l'annonce de Vladimir
Poutine qui ne se rendra pas au G20 à
Bali
la présence de Poutine sur ce groupe de
Javan c'est une acceptable parce que
c'est c'est pour le prince terroriste
qui attaque et qui est fait la guerre du
coup on a ce vertement que quand même ça
présence sera on peut dire en saute dans
les conditions que se présentent et
quand on a parlé aussi des pays de la
faillite des pays d'Asie oui bien sûr
c'est très important pour payer
différents pour attirer l'attention
depuis différentes mais quand même il
faut il faut se rappeler que le crème
aussi assez faire des efforts dans cette
région par exemple ministre des Affaires
étrangères que le bas il était en
Afrique il a essayé de présenter la
position au crayon là-bas même
malheureusement ce moment-là quand elle
a prévu le grand tour en Afrique c'était
le bombardement très fort de Kiev donc
du coup il a dû
revenir en Ukraine en urgence à cause de
cette situation mais récemment il était
en Cambodge donc il y a beaucoup aussi
de de visites des visites de haute de
région ukrainien dans les pays dans la
région où au passé on n'a pas eu des
visites donc maintenant l'Ukraine aussi
et c'est élargir la communication avec
le coin de mon différent Michel legaray
justement votre regard de militaire sur
des tractations possibles des
discussions possibles entre ukrainien et
russe en tout cas manifestement les
Américains seraient en train en coulisse
de les encourager ça vous semble être le
bon moment avec la situation sur le
terrain actuel
c'est toujours le moment de faire des
efforts et de garder une porte
entrouverte ça n'a que très peu de
choses à vous dire dans un dans un avion
proche parce que on a vu pour la
première fois le président zzinski a
reparlé de négociation mais il y a mis
cinq conditions qui sont bien évidemment
totalement inacceptables dans l'immédiat
par parler russe il faut dire aussi que
actuellement il est normal que président
zelinsky est une approche maximaliste
des négociations mais il a quand même
prononcé le mot à la suite d'ailleurs de
quelques visites de quelques hauts
fonctionnaires américains bien sûr qui
ont dû lui expliquer sont totalement
lutordre le bras qu'il fallait peut-être
faire un petit peu attention mais
Poutine n'est absolument pas en
situation d'accepter et dans une
situation dans lequel il reçoit des
fêtes sur des fêtes et sa propre
situation à Moscou n'est peut-être pas
aussi aussi certaines aussi sûre aussi
stables qu'on peut le croire s'il n'est
pas allé au G20 peut-être y a-t-il aussi
devant l'efferves de la rue que personne
ne n'envisageait à ce niveau là il y a
peut-être aussi un certain danger pour
son régime et pour lui-même moi je pense
que de toute façon aussi l'encourt
encore quelques revers de ce type là
c'est sa survie de son régime et sa
propre survie qui est en jeu
la capacité de la population russe
actuellement de éventuellement mettre en
danger le régime de Vladimir Poutine
matin il est clair que il est fragilisé
incontestablement pas forcément du côté
de la population mais du côté de ces
oligarques des gens qui l'entourent de
tout ça parce que bon il voit quand même
alors ça coûte très cher tout ça on en
parle jamais de ces sanctions mais elles
arrivent elles existent ces sanctions et
elle devient de plus en plus pesant plus
on avance dans le temple devient pesante
pour la pour la pour la Russie donc tout
ça ça pèse énormément sur le sur le
climat politique sur bon évidemment à un
moment donné si si
Poutine s'entête ses amis vont dire que
ça suffit et puis ils en moyenne se
débarrasser de lui un accident de
voiture un infarctus j'en sais rien un
plan peu importe
merci beaucoup Michel legareil d'avoir
pu nous rejoindre même si c'était pour
le dernier quart d'heure de cette
émission merci Oxana microfanova merci
beaucoup Denis stralcoff merci à vous
pardon Gulliver crack notre
correspondant à qui enfin qui nous a
quitté au milieu de l'émission merci
Gulliver merci à vous tous de nous avoir
suivis restez avec nous sur France 24